went out to albuquerque over there i
haven't talked to you since that
alba care care
somebody's like essay welcome to about
care care it's like how many care casts
are in abaca
i said man i'm happy to be here i said
he goes where and i said and they trick
you because they want to hear you say it
because they know you can't say it well
because nobody can because they can't
also
then the man said
i said i'm happy to be here and the guy
goes where and i was like
[Music]
hey kitty
and the guy's like oh you mean alba
can't get cat cat kick cat
this uh the whole day they don't even
if you look at it on the map it says
a-l-b-e-r-k
k-k-k-k-k and then has a bunch of just
dots
like what is it
one of the cues has a line going over
the top of it
you know like unlimited cues or whatever
damn you know
and one of the cues if you look real
close you can see him over there
carrying a couple other little cues on
his little
you know his little hip or whatever that
thing is a little goiter whatever cues
have on them
but damn it an albuquerque
that place is
that place is insane bruh
i never seen anything like that bro
people like dude they got aliens man
they got aliens bro
they have alvato that they got like area
uh quinceanos out there
hey dog
you believe in aria quincy uno
like what
yeah don't you know what i'm talking
about
ailing is papa
like what though
like que paso pero
oh dawg i'm talking about aliens don't
you like area 51 though you know what
i'm talking about ariel king uno
and i have a ticket
and dude the crazy part is everybody
there is talking about aliens
and the aliens are the people bro
we went into the um
we went to a love's gas station because
everything shuts down and now be hey
at probably about midnight
or probably 10 p.m
bro
we had to walk
because one of the uber said the command
said i ain't coming over there like all
right [ __ ] my all right
you know we'll figure it out we'll do
old-fashioned
so we walked you know the original ubers
baby you know i'm talking about feet and
kneecaps baby
that freaking ligament that them you
know
them little ligament uh
you know them bangers maybe them lifters
legs
i'm like all right we'll use these
[ __ ] and uh so we start walking
first guy we see
has a
sword
okay that's wild
guy had a sword on him he's a grown man
too
and we just didn't want to kind of he
was he was a lot he was walking around
but he could tell he was asleep
so he's one of those sleep swords
so it was just one of those he's almost
like one of those like on a game on a
video game if you don't get close to him
they don't know you're there kind of he
was like yeah so like all right let's
just maneuver around
um this little guardian
of the uh greyhound he was basically
guarding a greyhound station
um but anyway what was i talking about
oh albuquerque yeah but everybody there
they talk about the alien but the aliens
are they are amongst the people they're
so mixed in
and we went to a gas station and this
guy in there was just walking like
just like
he moved like his head he kept moving
his arms up above his heads while he
walked like oh dawg i'm looking for
some
rolos
i'm looking for what you might call it
and everybody there had a parole officer
with him
and that blew my mind
but that's solid police work
and um
and thank you that was that was great
man
over there and they have like again
they're like dog you gotta try the
chili's dawg have you had the green
chilies
dude somebody
that place is crazy dude uh
i went
i went to like this meeting there um
[Music]
you know i got 51 days sober right now
so
that's where i'm at and um
i'm feeling very grateful for that
uh
and so i went to this me and the other
dude i know you're not supposed to talk
about what happens in meetings that's
fine i was at a meeting once then i'll
say it like this and it was just me and
someone else and the man
was hitting on me bro in there
like dude i'm trying to get sober dog
not gayed out
you know so it was just like dang bro
you got to watch that stuff
so uh
if you're in a meeting and a guy takes
his shoes off dude
and um he started doing that cat's
cradle thing with his
shoelaces he took them out of his shoes
and was doing cats cradle with them
and my god you know
but um
but an abby hey
they always want you to try the green
chilies
people are like dog my cousin got
attacked by two guys with um
lightsabers you know
but
have you had the green chilies like
that's all it is there
it's like man my friend got run over by
a volkswagen but um
but have you had the green chilies
people like dude man uh my uh you know
my wife fell off a building last week
and it was
you know nobody knows what happened i
was up there with her and
we got an argument and she went off the
edge and uh
and damn have you had the green chilies
man because they are good
so it's just that kind of place is that
green chili belt over there and look i
will say this they are good
everybody in albuquerque
seem like they are waiting for a
greyhound bus even if they're not at a
greyhound station
i feel like everybody has luggage
um
yeah
everybody like has a ticket like i'm
waiting for the train
and they're just there's not even near
any tracks it's just this is a unique
area
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you